عاد امين وعمل وكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رفائيل جروسي من طهران متفائلا
بتعاون بناء مع ايران رغم التناقض في
تفسيره للاتفاق الذي توصل اليه هناك مع
التفسير الايراني ولكن نبره غروسيا
المتفائله يبدو انها كافيه هذه المره
لتجنيب ايران اي قرار جديد ضدها داخل مجلس
المحافظين وتحدث جروسي في مؤتمر صحفي
فيينا عن الاتفاق مع المسؤولين الايرانيين
على تعاون في تحقيق الوكاله حول المواقع
النوويه السريه وحول تفسير العثور على اثر
يورانيوم مخصب في منشاه فوردو بنسبه
84%
كنا ندور في حلقه مفرغه والان انطباع بان
هناك فرصه للابتعاد عن هذه الحلقه ونرى
حقا تقدما في هذه النقاط وخاصه في منشاه
فوردو التي ستخدع لمراقبه المفتشين كل
يومين
ومع ذلك ما ازال الكثير من الالتزامات
التي حصل عليها غراسي مجرد كلامنا لا
يختلف عن السابقليف
هناك فرصه جيده ولكن لا يمكنني ان اضمن
الناس يقولون هي وعود وهي ليست وعودا
لدينا بعض الاتفاقات المحسوسه وفي الوقت
نفسه يجب ان استمر بالقيام بعمل
وبالمحاوله
ورغم كلامي غروستي
لاخذ اجوبه من ايران فهو قال بانه سيطلع
المجلس على نتائج المحدثات في ايران او
غيابها قد تكون الدول الغربيه اعطت ايران
فرصه جديده للتعاون مع الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه بعد ان ابلغ جروستي مجلس
المحافظين بان الوعود هذه المره مختلفه
ولكن اي شعور بالمواطنه من طرف ايران قد
تلمسه الدول الغربيه سيدفعها للتصعيد
مجددا في الاجتماع المقبل لمجلس المحافظين
او حتى اقرب من خلال الدعوه للاجتماع طارق
اذا لزم الامر راغده بهنام العربيه فينا